ALL RIGHT.
NOW THAT THE REPUBLICAN FIELD IS
SEEMINGLY COMPLETE, I THOUGHT
I'D BRING ON OUR POLITICAL
EXPERT MIKE YARD TO DISCUSS
TRUMP AND WHICH CANDIDATE MIGHT
HAVE THE BEST CHANCE OF WINNING
THE BLACK VOTE.
MIKE YARD, EVERYBODY.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
HOW YOU DOING, MIKE?
>> HEY, WHAT'S UP, LARRY?
Larry: SO, MIKE, IT SOUNDS
LIKE JOHN KASICH IS TRYING TO
SOUND INCLUSIVE.
DO YOU THINK HE CAN APPEAL TO
THE BLACK VOTE?
>> THE BLACK VOTE'S ALREADY
WRAPPED UP.
IT'S TRUMP.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Larry: WAIT, TRUMP?
YEAH LARRY, THIS GUY IS '90s
HIP-HOP, ALL DAY.
MAN!
(LAUGHTER)
THINK ABOUT IT.
TRUMP LIKES GOLD.
(LAUGHTER)
HE ROLLS DEEP.
HE HAD HIS OWN VODKA.
(LAUGHTER)
HE'S GOT HIS OWN COLOGNE.
HE'S GOT TONS OF BABY MAMAS.
(LAUGHTER)
HE'S HAD COURT APPEARANCES.
AND HE'S DEALT WITH
BANKRUPTCIES.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Larry: WOW.
THAT IS AMAZING.
WAIT.
HOLD ON.
SO YOU THINK BLACK PEOPLE LIKE
HIM BECAUSE HE SEEMS LIKE A
'90s RAPPER?
>> '90s, EARLY AUGHTS,
WHATEVER.
(LAUGHTER)
I MEAN, LOOK, DID YOU SEE WHEN
HE PISSED OFF NEIL YOUNG BY
USING HIS MUSIC?
THIS DUDE IS EVEN JACKING BEATS,
LARRY!
(LAUGHTER)
>> Larry: JACKING BEATS?
(APPLAUSE)
>> YES.
Larry: ALL RIGHT.
OKAY.
I GUESS I CAN SEE WHY BLACK
PEOPLE WOULD VOTE FOR HIM.
WAIT,
BUT ISN'T HE PISSING EVERYBODY
OFF?
MUSICIANS, MEXICANS, JOHN
McCAIN.
>> EXACTLY.
EXACTLY, LARRY.
THE DUDE'S GOT BEEF WITH
EVERYBODY!
(LAUGHTER)
HE'S LIKE THE 50 CENT OF THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
(LAUGHTER)
I'M TELLING YOU, MAN.
ALL HE NEEDS IS TO GET SHOT NINE
TIMES, AND HE'S GOLDEN.
>> Larry: HOLD ON.
HOLD ON.
(LAUGHTER)
(APPLAUSE)
>> I'M TELLING YOU.
I'M TELLING YOU.
(LAUGHTER)
I'M TELLING YOU, MAN.
DID YOU CHECK OUT HIS BEEF WITH
LINDSEY GRAHAM?
>> Larry: OH, YEAH.
DIDN'T HE CALL TRUMP A JACKASS?
>> UH-HUH.
AND WHAT'D TRUMP DO?
>> SO LINDSAY GRAHAM SAID,
PLEASE, PLEASE, WHATEVER YOU CAN
DO. AND HE GAVE ME HIS NUMBER.
I FOUND THE CARD,
202-228-[ BLEEP ].
SO I DON'T KNOW.
GIVE IT A SHOT.
>> HE GAVE OUT A UNITED STATES
SENATOR'S PRIVATE CELL PHONE
NUMBER!
THAT'S STRAIGHT-UP GANGSTA,
LARRY!
(LAUGHTER)
>> I KNOW.
Larry: YOU'RE RIGHT.
CLASSIC '90s HIP-HOP.
>> YES!
THAT'S BIGGIE/TUPAC STYLE.
ALL TODAY.
(LAUGHTER)
BACK WHEN [ BLEEP ] WAS REAL.
>> Larry: SO HOW WILL THIS
AFFECT THE RACE IF TRUMP HAS THE
BLACK VOTE LOCKED UP?
>> AFFECT HIM?
THE RACE IS OVER, BROTHER.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Larry: WAIT.
YOU THINK TRUMP'S GOING TO WIN
THE REPUBLICAN PRIMARY?
>> YES!
WHITE PEOPLE LOVE HIP-HOP TOO!
AND REPUBLICANS LOVE IT EVEN
MORE COMING FROM A WHITE GUY.
TRUMP IS THE MACKLEMORE
CANDIDATE.
(LAUGHTER)
(APPLAUSE)
>> Larry: OKAY.
OPEN UP YOUR EYES.
Larry: LET ME ASK YOU THIS,
MIKE.
DOES THAT MEAN YOU THINK TRUMP
CAN BEAT HILLARY?
>> YOU MEAN SUGE KNIGHT?
(LAUGHTER)
LARRY, ARE YOU ASKING ME IF
MACKLEMORE CAN BEAT SUGE KNIGHT?
(LAUGHTER)
LARRY, ANSWER THAT YOURSELF.
>> Larry: IT'S NOT REALLY WHAT I
SAID.
BUT I THINK THE ANSWER'S NO.
>> THERE YOU GO.
Larry: MIKE YARD, EVERYBODY.